I know hungry I wasn't hungry
don't be baby hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans coming at you from the famous
kitchen of munchy where I'm joined by
machi she's the face behind the
tremendously popular YouTube channel
will week over week she schools her
audience and some of Korea's finest
culinary exports and that's why we're
here today to learn how to make
perfectly crisp perfectly crunchy Korean
fried chicken that's right maangchi has
opened up her home to us to get the
double fried guide on how to make one of
the greatest chicken dishes in the
entire world but first things first what
is the biggest difference between Korean
fried chicken and then something I might
pick up in a box over here in 48th
Street first thing first
I gotta say one word thank you so much
Shan because of your good compliment is
just oh my I'm so happy thank you thank
you thank you for coming to my house
thank you for having me amazing
yeah anyway I don't know much about
other types of the chicken only I know a
lot about Korean fried chicken it's the
fried a double fry you mentioned this
right and this cream cheese and
sometimes a seasoning with the mix with
the seasoning sauce the seasoning sauce
is all that depending on the restaurant
favorite restaurant
I cooked my cool so like you Jody spicy
sometimes a sweet and sometimes a sweet
sour spicy where do you fall on it do
you like it spicy do you like it sweet
do you like it in the middle I like it
spicy it's a very special day I'm
humbled and blessed to be here what are
the ingredients what are we working with
today two pounds of a chicken
ion's of chicken wash the Aunt Peggy to
drive with my paper
how is so clean waiting for you we're
gonna add so so this is 1/4 teaspoon
okay put some yeah yeah yeah be brave
okay more got it one more go be great
for a teaspoon okay hit it with some
pepper
yeah quarter teaspoon ground freshly
ground black pepper
a my baldness and then this is a baking
soda for a teaspoon and then he's flour
ask me what kind of flour
what kind of flower is this whole
purpose of flour all-purpose flour
yeah yes my wife that one this one yeah
this is a 1/3 cup 1/4 cup flour and this
is make it crunchy so this is such
potato starch or corn starch so can you
add I got it ok and this is this is the
crispy yeah and then let's click one egg
oh there we go
should i mix what you wanna meet I'll
mix it up yeah yeah mix this up okay mix
it so did you know Steelworkers hands
like this you don't want to waste them
angry I can help you too you and me
making chicken let's all play chicken
please
[Music]
alright so we'll know when the oil is
ready once it hits 350 right we have our
wings coated and before I move on can
you speak a little bit about fried
chickens place in Korean culture because
I know that in South Korea alone there's
over 50,000 fried chicken restaurants
the chicken and beer thing seems to be
such a big deal can you explain that to
me
yeah actually the Korean fried chicken
it was a popular since the 1980s so far
and before then we about different kinds
of a chicken usually in roasted chicken
by electricity but this Korean fried
chicken was around at that time like a
Korea has some
economically some problem and the Ladin
people lost the job so they need to
survive so they just open the restaurant
so chicken was a suddenly just going up
so I always I love the Korean fried
chicken I'm so excited so not everybody
has a thermometer editor it's true so
why you Judy if we don't have any no
thermometer you can do this I usually
put his'n deep like a tip over this
chicken and you see the bubbles yeah
we're really small bubbles coming up
that's a perfect is 350 now it's not to
cooking fail so yeah you want to do
slowly slowly
this is a 2 pounds of chicken this oh it
is around the 7 8 cups of oil around in
a two and a three inch it depth so just
we can do this only one batch all right
so we've dropped our 2 pounds of chicken
how long do we keep it here we have a
timer yeah now we're just around ujt 12
minutes I caught it
is it almost the one number right this
wow isn't it looking good looking good
yeah it's smelling good no I know hungry
I wasn't hungry
don't be baby so I'm going to turn down
the heat it's just a little bit because
I don't want to burn
how'd you get into the YouTube cooking
game do you remember like your first
video and remember how I started of
course
and my first video was I see stuff right
squid next day a lot of people subscribe
and then they ask could me manche 20mg
gear please kimchi please more and more
requests became okay I followed their
requests now almost 11 years so far it's
amazing it's amazing so you kind of just
blew up right away yeah exactly
before that I was almost addicted to own
90 online games you got your name to the
hammer in Korea right I have a monkey
character and also another is of Sankar
doubles world and also another one is a
two more in a gangster boss so I played
with all nine game all of the world so
that's the belt which means are fried
number one is just about done
yeah I'll dig the tongs in here awesome
pass it over to the strainer yeah even
it deletes delicious looking light
golden brown
it looks ready to go yeah yeah but you
don't want to eat it yeah you want to
fry it again
yeah and why do you want to fry it again
he might be cooked enough but soggy so
what I wanted real crunchy outside
inside is still juicy we got a here okay
we gotta hear it ten minutes I am cool
again okay so mean why we make the deuce
salsa easy piece of cake
no problem alright so we have our second
fry in we have our alarm set for ten
maybe it needs eleven maybe it needs
twelve then decide down the road but now
it's time to make some sauce what are
the ingredients for the sauce here of
course we need the garlic that's the
myth of three garlic cloves have you
ever worked with such a good chicken
watcher in all your life no you are the
first and best one more ingredient what
you done Korean hot pepper piece what's
special about the gochujang why is it
important for this dish kochujang is the
little spicy and make a color red and
also kochujang has a kind of a deep
earthy flavor you know so the flavor
makes it really nice I need a quarter
cup yeah okay and then this is a
cha-cha-cha we use a tomato ketchup yeah
is it because your color is red and
little sweet sour taste 1/3 a cup
ketchup zero is the same amount 1/3 cup
and when you go around the 2 teaspoons 2
teaspoon oh yeah so vegetable oil I use
or you can use a corn oil canola oil ten
minutes past but I think we will start
the cooking because a really nice golden
brown it looks good it looks good we're
done that time yeah yeah it sounded
structurally sound ok God Lisa coming
garlic's coming shiny the studying I'm
stirring okay there's things going hmm
you can't stop me once I start okay so
did it crunchy you know you see okay say
one time time to this damn it's all
happening okay I would turn down the
heat to make a seizure so I don't want
to burn yeah okay shiny sweet spicy and
kind of a Korean put you down flavor the
sauce hot chicken and sizzling sauce yay
let's go
he was like we were together yeah it is
perfect amazing
even though without the tasting I know
what it tastes like very crunchy
creature outside the inside is so juicy
okay done
and then sesame seeds I saw that you
really sprinkle rare Wow where did you
learn this is not in my recipe but this
is the kind of a secret
so chili flakes I see if you don't like
somebody and you like to torture him
well then you can say that all these
Korean spicy chicken and you make just a
to Table two scoops and then he's going
to eat one in u.s. laughing double fried
double scooped I can't wait to see you
tasted it this is for you shun yeah I'm
I can't wait to eat I'm hungry
hmm-hmm I didn't ups oh my gosh pie see
it is yeah let's clear out the counter
let's serve up a plate sure yes you eat
together
let's eat together that long last the
tutorial has ended now nothing to do but
have some lunch cheers my team Oh Cheers
thank you for having us thank you cut me
[Music]
thank you it was so good cooked
perfectly
I hear my crunch it is spicy but that's
how we like it over here at first we
feast
I have eaten many a fried chicken drum
in my life but Mon chief this one is one
of the best and that's why you have to
go over to Monty's YouTube page you
gotta smash that subscribe button so
that you too can learn how to make
delicious meals just like this thank you
again
till next time internet for first me
feast I'm Sean in it thank you so much
for coming and enjoy my chicken
[Music]
so I can take it mm-hmm and then I kind
of cover okay awesome
oh my god so polite everybody will love
you organs we love you because it is so
polite thank you